hey guys check out this mechanical drop
set for building big biceps this is
actually really intense so you'll only
need two sets and you shouldn't need any
other direct bicep training for the
entire week so I'm starting here with
curls using a way I can do about 10 good
reps with once I reach failure my swap
immediately to cross body hammer curls
using the same weight this is now easier
as it focuses on the brachialis thanks
to the neutral hand position brachialis
is a muscle situated more deeply in the
arm and it's actually stronger than the
bicep when I switch again immediately to
cheat hammer curls I'm cheating by
swinging the weight up but notice I'm
not leaning back I'm generating the
momentum from my legs not my back that's
pointless some people will say but in
fact this long set with high continuous
time and detention is amazing for
increasing blood flow to the muscles via
angiogenesis it also engages fast twitch
fiber by exhausting the slow twitch and
through hypoxia it creates tons of
muscle damage and metabolic buildup just
try it yourself and see